from mcdonald's to domino's we wanted to
find out all the biggest portion size
differences between uk and us fast food
this is food wars
this is what a small drink looks like in
the uk this
is a u.s small this is what a medium
drink looks like
this is a us medium this is a lodge
oh and this is a u.s
large
so with our mcnuggets in the uk the
default adult sizes on the menu
are a box of six a box of nine
or a share box of 20. nuggets
get a box of four or you can get a six
piece
or ten twenty
for sharing or
40. and according to the three
mcdonald's in the area they don't have
20 or 40 boxes they just
do them in increments of 10. but this is
on the menu
just out of curiosity we're going to
bring our trusty friend the scales back
and we're gonna weigh the big mac and
see if there is any difference in size
i'm not sure there will be but let's
find out
this is what a regular popcorn chicken
looks like in the uk
and this is what a large popcorn chicken
looks like
in the u.s we have a large popcorn
chicken
and if you want to go even larger than
the large and get yourself a popcorn
chicken
box something for you and your buddies
i'm sure
not eating this by yourself
did i lose any no no way am i doing this
without
oh don't jinx it
[Music]
this is a regular fries and this
is a large prize here's the us regular
right you want to go the next size up
this is the u.s large
look at how big that is it's like five
of those ones that he had
let's find out how much a large prize
weighs in the uk
let's weigh our large fry
oh man
they're packed in there dude look at
that
is that everything in the uk you can get
buckets in three sizes
you can get a six piece
you can get a 10 piece
or you can get a 14 piece
eight piece whoa
12-piece
this is i'm not gonna i can't even dump
it
yo look how much chicken this
is oh my god
in the uk we have three drink sizes
we have a small which is 250 milliliters
this is a us smart we have a regular
which is 400 milliliters
this is a us medium and we have
a lodge in here
the u.s large burger king
now in the uk we have three sizes of
fries small regular
and large here's a burger king small fry
here's a burger king medium fry
and a burger king large fry
so the three sizes of fries that we were
given i'm actually not sure which one is
the regular and which one is the small
because these two kind of look identical
we're going to weigh them all
we're going to start with this orange
bottomed bag
80.
88 grams now we're gonna weigh the
slightly darker orange bag
and see which size this is
so there's only a five gram difference
but this one
is b small
[Music]
so a large fries in the uk looks like
it's around 180 grams which is double
the regular
we're actually having some concerns
about the sizes of the fries in the uk
because our measurements showed that the
lighter orange bag actually contains
more fries
than the darker orange bag however when
lined up
very scientifically like this what we'll
actually see is that
the bag sizes go up in that color order
instead
so i think what's happened here is that
our small was actually bigger than our
regular
wow a lot of fried drama over there in
the uk as you can see from our sizes
it's pretty obvious with the small
medium larges
but of course we're still gonna weigh
them so let's start with the small fry
yup oh rogue fry and now the medium fry
i'm making a face and i like that face
it's like
yeah it's pretty similar but i know how
we will solve this
but not not that way
over here burger king is in the hot seat
baby burger king's in the hot seats
large fries so i'm going to do something
really tedious and boring
2 3 4 12
13 20 21 22 35 regulars
10 kind of broken up ones one
two three four and eighteen but they'll
have smaller ones
whoa that's pretty cold burger king that
is pretty cold
don't act like you're surprised by this
and i know what they're going to say
they're going to be like well everyone
who scoops is different
okay but our scooper here and their
scooper in the uk
made a similar error hmm
suspicious right
frygate 2020. so this
is a whopper in the uk
no it's not that's a halloumi king is
this the water
burger king
[Music]
so what we're going to do is weigh a
whopper and see how much a whopper
weighs in the uk
all right let's take a look at the us
whopper first thing i'm gonna do
i'm gonna weigh it oh yeah
that's a whopper
this is the smallest pizza you can get
in the uk it's called an individual
and it measures seven inches across our
smallest is believe it or not
the small here it is and it measures in
diameter
10 inches the next size up is a small
which measures 9.5 inches next size up
for the us
is our medium which is 12 inches
this is 11.5 inches
well i'm starving hey
i grabbed the slice i'm starving this
pizza smells so good let's get breakfast
next pizza next up for the us is our
large which is a 14
inch diameter oh hell yeah
what's with the way they cut your large
pizza harry it's ridiculous look at that
and not to be outdone the u.s has one
more size
the extra large diameter 16
inches bro look at the size of this
thing
now a 2.5 inch difference might not
sound like a lot but if you factor that
into the surface area
it's actually 58 square inches wider
than the uk's largest pizza
which is almost a third of an increase
am i looking at this right is it
supposed to be six slices it's six
slices that can't be right
six slices for a extra-large pizza look
at the size of these slices
[Music]
now hot coffees in the uk come in four
sizes
firstly we have a short coffee which is
eight ounces the short eight ounces
then we have a tall coffee which is
twelve ounces next we have the tall
next 12 ounces it's a grande coffee
which comes in
at 16 ounces then we got the grande
16 ounces aventi or 20 ounces
ah sensational and the biggest one the
venti
20 ounces
in case you're wondering it's called the
venti because 20
in italian is venti tuento
just to double check we're going to
measure the largest hot coffee in the uk
so our venti coffee actually came to
closer to 18 ounces sort that out
starbucks
where's my two ounces now i'm going to
measure
the venti coffee which should be 20
ounces
minus a few sips
wait
okay prepared
whoa come on i did not drink that much
oh starbucks that's not no that's not
even two that's like an ounce
the cold coffees in the uk come in three
sizes
they're tall the tall 12 ounces
grande we got the grande
and fenty here's where things get kind
of weird our venti iced
is 24 ounces and we have another size up
20 right trent
and that is 30 ounces
so a uk cold venti is exactly 20 ounces
yeah 21. i thought this was supposed to
be 24.
how many fluid ounces
venti nice
24 and how much is it 21
starbucks with the ice you still don't
have enough
the subway in the uk you can get
sandwiches in four different sizes
firstly we have toasted bites
a six inch sub a foot long sub
and then you can get
a platter and in the u.s
we have three sizes the six inch
the foot long yeah you go
for you and your team ah
the big boy party platter
the old subway platypus now in the uk a
platter looks like this
what they do is they make four foot long
sandwiches then they cut those into
fours
so you're left with 16 pieces each of
which
is three inches and for the party
platter here
they take five sandwiches cutting them
into three pieces giving you 15
sandwiches total
in addition in the u.s you can also get
yourself
a three foot long party sub
look at this thing this is ridiculous uh
three feet so that is what's that in
what do you got in the uk it's 17 meters
i have no idea
yeah if you're a fan of subway's cookies
in the uk those come in three sizes
one cookie
three cookies four
twelve cookies in the u.s subway you can
get
a single cookie
dozen cookies like that
or the
hang on the
36 cookie platter booyah
[Laughter]
like in vegas baby all in